[Applaudissements]
que diriez-vous de schémas de l'anatomie
génitales omettant un organe érectile
d'environ dix centimètres de long et que
diriez-vous d'une éducation à la
sexualité omettant de parler de l'organe
qui est la source primaire du plaisir
sexuel chez la moitié de l'humanité
ça serait pas top en est d'accord il ya
pourtant c'est ce qu'on fait encore
aujourd'hui massivement avec un organe
féminin cet organe c'est le clitoris
alors il ya une raison simple à ça c'est
qu'il ne sert qu'au plaisir sexuel des
femmes et que ce plaisir n'a aucun
impact sur la reproduction
quand ça a été bien établie vers la fin
du 19e siècle et bien la connaissance
anatomique et fonctionnelle du clitoris
qui était déjà acquise à l'époque pour
l'essentiel a été relégué au second plan
bah oui là c'est le plaisir sexuel des
femmes on s'en fiche et un dès lors
qu'elles assuraient leur fonction
sociale de gestatrice mer & company
transmettre cette connaissance est
devenu inutile et même gênant puisque
parler du clitoris revient à s'aventurer
sur le terrain
moralement glissant du plaisir sexuel
déconnecté de la reproduction
c'est gênant aussi parce que ça laisse
voir combien la sexualité des femmes
peut s'émanciper de la satisfaction des
désirs des hommes
c'est donc aussi un contexte social
hétéronormatif et inégalitaire qui fait
que le clitoris reste méconnu le
problème c'est que réciproquement
cette méconnaissance laisse la place à
des idées fausses qui conforte le
sexisme avec son cortège d'inégalités et
d'autres conséquences néfastes
déjà rien que le fait d'ignorer que le
clitoris et le pénis sont les organes
homologues issus du phallus embryonnaire
mais ça laisse la place à l'idée que
notre sexe développerait soit en paix ni
ce soit en vagin or sur cette base il
peut être tentant de distinguer
symboliquement les hommes par la
possession d'un organe qui serait absent
chez les femmes
il est tentant aussi de voir le sexe des
femmes comme un vide ou un réceptacle
destiné à skis les comblerait
naturellement la forme de leurs organes
sexuels des rendre est par essence
réceptive plutôt active les destinerait
à l'accueil du désir de l'autre
ensuite ignorait qu exactement comme le
pénis le clitoris et fonctionnel dès la
naissance et restent toute la vie la
principale zone érogène basse a aussi
des conséquences concrètes
la masturbation est vue comme moins
naturel pour les filles et les femmes
alors outre le malaise que ça peut
susciter quand elle la pratique
incertaine se trouve incapable ce qui
les prive non seulement d'un d'une
source de bien-être mais aussi d'un
moyen de développement de tout leur
potentiel de plaisir sexuel
alors partant de l'idée que une femme et
censés jouir par son vagin
grâce au va et vient d'un pénis
certaines femmes se croient à tort
frigide ou anormal pourtant toutes les
enquêtes montrent que peu de femmes sont
pleinement satisfaites par le coït
vaginal
par exemple dans une étude récente faite
aux états unis moins d'une sur cinq a
déclaré lettres et près des trois quarts
ont déclaré que stimuler en même temps
leur clitoris était nécessaire soit pour
atteindre l'orgasme soit pour avoir une
meilleure jouissance de manière plus
générale l'ignorance autour du clitoris
temps à enfermer les couples hétéros
dans des scénarios sexuels andros entrée
qui sont trop souvent insatisfaisant
pour les femmes
on constate d'ailleurs qu'il existe une
inégalité aussi dans l'axé à l'orgasme
par exemple actuellement aux etats unis
95% des hommes hétéros 10 l'atteindre
habituellement avec leur partenaire
contre seulement 65 % des femmes et tvo
pour les femmes homos on remarque que ça
va déjà nettement mieux
en fait la méconnaissance du clitoris
mais aussi une pression indue sur les
hommes qui s'imaginent à tort qu'ils
doivent absolument être performants avec
leur pénis 1 que s'ils ont une panne
d'érection aussi déjà culte rothau eh
bien ils seront incapables de faire
jouer une femme
alors pour ma part c'est la masturbation
qui m'a confronté pour la première fois
à l'omerta sur le clitoris
je devais avoir 5 ans je comprenais pas
ce que je faisais tout ce que je savais
c'est que c'était hyper agréable hyper
frustrant d'arrêter une fois commencée
et sans doute honteux ou anormales
puisque personne n'en parlait ça s'est
pas arrangée avec l'explication de
l'appareil génital en cours de sciences
naturelles
c'était pas du vagin que me venaient ces
sensations et visiblement j'avais un
truc qu aucune femme n'avait on m'a
jamais appris que j'avais un clitoris
quand j'ai finalement su je me rappelle
m'être explorer avec un miroir sans bien
comprendre à quoi ils correspondent
exactement
je me souviens aussi que pendant des
années j'ai continué à penser que
j'étais sans doute pas normal parce que
ce que je faisais est ce que je
ressentais ce soit seul ou à deux ben ça
collait pas avec ce que je savais de
l'anatomie c'est seulement en 2004 que
j'ai enfin compris grâce à un
documentaire de la réalisatrice michèle
dominici inspiré par les recherches de
l'urologue hélène o'connell enfin j'ai
su à quoi ressemblaient vraiment le
clitoris
j'ai pu mettre une image mentale sur mes
sensations qui leur donner sens et
cohérence plus tard devenu chercheuse
étudiants les billets sexistes dans les
discours biologique sur les différences
femmes hommes
j'ai constaté qu'aucun manuels scolaires
de présenter correctement le clitoris
quand il n'était pas carrément absents
mais ils étaient réduits à une petite
boule ou un flajolet sans jamais
d'explication de sa fonction ni de
définition correcte alors que je
préparais des vidéos pédagogiques anti
sexistes visant à compenser ce qui
clochait dans les manuels
j'ai donc eu l'idée de montrer dans
l'une d'elles à quoi il ressemblait
c'est comme ça que j'ai été amené à
créer un modèle de clitoris imprimable
en 3d pour ce faire j'ai épluché toute
la littérature scientifique disponible
et sur cette base j'ai défini une forme
stylisée et des dimensions moyennes
plausible le fab lab de la cité des
sciences à paris m'a ensuite aidé à
transformer ces données en un modèle 3d
et c'est comme ça qu'une première
version a été créé
fin 2016 via un petit peu améliorée avec
l'aide d'un prof de svt féru
d'informatique et on a aussi mis à
disposition une page html qui permet de
le voir sous toutes les coutures
alors voici à quoi ça ressemble on voit
qu'il est constitué de deux structures
reliés par un réseau de veines en rousse
claire c'est celle qui contient le gland
la seule partie visible du clitoris plus
ou moins cachés par le capuchon et les
deux corps caverneux d'abord rejoint
pour former le corps du clitoris puis se
séparant pour former ses piliers
l'ensemble mesure de l'ordre de 10 cm en
moyenne de la pointe du gland celle d'un
pilier en rose plus foncée ce sont les
bulbes ils sont faits d'un tissu
semblable à celui des corps caverneux
ces deux types de tissus très
particulier sont les mêmes que dans le
pénis ils contiennent des cavités qui se
gonfle de sang sous l'effet de
l'excitation sexuelle
donc cette excitation se traduit aussi
chez les femmes par une érection
elle est régie par les mêmes mécanismes
que celle du pénis et soit dit en
passant elle est tout aussi rapide et
potentiellement intempestives
alors les piliers sont fixés aux eaux du
bassin et les bulles sont à cheval sur
l'urètre et le vagin
je précise que le clitoris n'a pas de
ramifications à l'intérieur du vagin et
que son direction n'a pas pour effet
d'ouvrir le vagin je signale aussi que
les bulbes ne sont pas proches du canal
anal
en tout cas ils le sont moins que le
bulbe du pénis chez les hommes
alors grâce à l'impression 3d le modèle
disponible en ligne gratuitement permet
d'obtenir cet objet il est utilisé en
cours de svt pour faire de l'éducation
sexuelle pour parler de l'excision ou de
l'intersexuation ou encore en
sexothérapie le manipuler permet d'avoir
une conscience claire de sa forme et de
sa taille
ça permet aussi de montrer les quatre
grands lieux possibles de sa stimulation
chacun associe à des sensations
différentes plus ou moins apprécié selon
les femmes selon le moment et selon la
méthode employée
on peut le stimuler au niveau du gland
la zone la plus riche en récepteurs
sensoriels au niveau de la partie
distale du corps du clitoris par dessus
le capuchon là où passent aussi des
nerfs sensitifs et des veines importante
par l'intérieur du vagin au niveau de la
base du corps du clitoris bon à noter
que pour ça le pénis n'est en principe
pas l'outil idéal ou encore plus
indirectement par une compression des
bulbes qui va chasser leur sang vers la
partie réellement sensible du clitoris
alors le buzz généré par cet objet a
commencé à faire bouger les choses par
exemple en 2010 est un dessin de
clitoris entier est enfin paru dans un
manuel scolaire
mais il reste encore beaucoup à faire et
je pense qu'il est vraiment temps les
enjeux symboliques psychologique et
pratiques associées à la connaissance du
clitoris en font un élément
incontournable du progrès vers l'égalité
et vers la prise en main par les femmes
de leur sexualité
alors j'espère que vous aussi vous
contribuerez à diffuser cette
connaissance
merci
[Applaudissements]